this is what would happen if your skin  were bulletproof  this could be possible one day a dutch  research team has created bulletproof  skin using spider silk which they  combined with human cells  they found that this piece of skin could  stop a bullet but only if it wasn't  traveling at full speed  spider silk is three times stronger than  kevlar and five times stronger than  steel if all humans had this kind of  skin it would prevent thousands if not  millions of deaths worldwide  but that doesn't mean bulletproof skin  would be perfect as you'd still feel the  impact of the bullet getting hit by one  would at best feel like the hardest  punch you've ever felt and at worst it  could easily break your bones  then who's to say that gun manufacturers  wouldn't just develop weapons powerful  enough to penetrate bulletproof skin so  even though this would help you  definitely wouldn't be invincible  because